For any of these points I'm going to start at the origin, count over in either
direction, as many slots as I need to horizontally. And then, count either up or
down. So it's going to give me first the x value, and then the y value of that
point. So for point a, I need to count over 1, 2, 3, 4. I can see that this is
the vertical line that a lies on, and then I need to come up this line toward a,
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7. So a must be the point for 7. I can do the same thing for
b, starting at the origin. I count in the negative direction, 1, 2, 3, 4, 6, 6.
So my x coordinate is negative 6. And then from there, I count up to b, 1, 2, 3,
4, 5. For point c, once again the x value is negative, since it's to the left of
the origin, 1, 2, 3, 4. So negative 4. And then c has a negative y value, since
it's below the x axis. So from here I need to count down negative 1, negative 2,
negative 3, negative 4. And last but not least, d has a positive x value, 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 6, and a negative y value, negative 1, 2. So it's the point 6, negative
2.